this summer philip and i finally managed
to buy a new house and i am in love with
it but let me tell you it wasn't easy we
had to search for almost a year put in
multiple offers and routinely had to go
above asking price the housing market
here in central texas like most places
feels out of control the median home
price in austin has almost doubled in
the last few years which reflects a
trend in many places across the nation
some of this can be blamed on the
coronavirus pandemic the cost of
construction materials went way up
construction of new homes slowed way
down and a lot of people canceled their
plans to put their houses on the market
i mean who would want a bunch of
strangers touring your home with a
deadly virus on the loose
but like lots of economic and social
trends kovid only accelerated things
that were already in motion there are
deeper reasons why it's getting so
expensive to buy a house in america
these days and the solutions feel pretty
far off
[Music]
to really understand what's going on in
the housing market today we have to go
back to 2008 when the last housing
bubble burst
years of reckless lending by wall street
had artificially inflated the market
sending home prices soaring when it
finally became clear that too many
people had taken out predatory loans to
buy overpriced houses the whole thing
collapsed taking the u.s economy with it
real estate values plummeted thousands
of people lost their homes and there
were too many houses on the market with
not enough people who could buy them
when a market reacts to a shock it tends
to overreact construction of new homes
fell from 2 million a year to less than
500 000
the decade following the great recession
had the fewest number of homes built
than any decade since the 1960s there's
also fewer existing homes being put up
for sale advances in medicine and
nutrition have kept the baby boomers
healthier and more productive longer
than their parents so they're not ready
to retire sell the house and move to a
condo in florida just yet meanwhile
millennials who've had to delay home
buying for financial reasons like
stagnant wages and student debt are
finally ready to enter the market in big
numbers mortgage rates are at historic
lows which means more people can afford
to get a loan the rise of remote working
means that more workers want houses away
from city centers but there's just not
enough units available that means
bidding wars and rising prices across
the country a report by the national
association of realtors estimates that
to make up the shortage the u.s would
have to build over 2 million homes per
year for 10 years
more than we were building during the
last housing boom
so far the rates on permits for new
homes are nowhere near where they need
to be to hit that goal one reason is
that well america is a little rusty at
building houses when construction slowed
way down during the 2010s demand for
skilled trades people dried up a lot of
boomers retired from careers like
carpentry plumbing and electrical and
far fewer young people entered the
fields to replace them since it can take
years for someone to become proficient
we are currently experiencing a massive
shortage of skilled trades people just
when we need them the most developers
often have to delay construction to find
professional labor sometimes even
shipping them in from other regions this
means fewer houses built per year at
higher cost
many cities are implementing programs to
attract and train new skilled trades
people but in the meantime there's a
much bigger obstacle to building our way
out of this housing shortage
zoning laws
believe it or not in most of the united
states it's illegal to build anything
but single family detached homes
no duplexes no condos no apartments not
even a granny flat many of these laws
date back to the early 20th century and
allowed white homeowners to stop any
development they feared would lower the
value of their property today these laws
are strictest in big wealthy cities like
san francisco new york and seattle here
in austin there has been a long campaign
to try to re-zone much of the city to
allow for denser residential areas
called codenext but it's been stuck in
legal limbo for years due to the
tireless opposition of mostly white
affluent homeowners who want to preserve
the look and demographics of their
neighborhoods regardless of skyrocketing
home prices and surging houseless
population
this social group also tends to have the
highest turnout in local elections
across the country so if you want to
serve another term on the city council
you better vote against that affordable
apartment building law professor david
schleicher argues that these zoning
restrictions impact the overall economy
as well by suppressing wages for example
when an area experiences a period of
economic growth the higher wages should
attract job seekers from across the
socio-economic spectrum but if zoning
laws prohibit the construction of new
homes the only people who can afford to
relocate there are already wealthy in
other words if you're a janitor living
in reno nevada you could conceivably
make more as a janitor in silicon valley
except there's no housing there in your
price range california is a prime
example of the dangers of nimbyism short
for not in my backyard
some even call it a banana state build
absolutely nothing anywhere near anyone
despite a decade of high output and
employment skyrocketing home prices have
forced many middle and low wage workers
to relocate to other states what should
have been a boom economy for everyone
was only available to the affluent
educated professionals who could afford
to enter bidding wars over the small
inventory of existing homes
nimbi-ism also affects our ability to
build infrastructure in america one mile
of commuter rail in the u.s can be
several times more expensive than in
europe one reason is that european
governments typically have more power to
plan and execute infrastructure projects
from start to finish in america even a
small group of local homeowners can
derail any building proposal they don't
like often using historical or
environmental concerns as justifications
these delays and legal battles
drastically drive up the cost of
construction organizations from the
urban institute to the national
association of realtors are calling on
governments to make it easier to build
new construction
president biden has proposed including
in his infrastructure bill financial
incentives to areas that are willing to
relax their zoning laws though that may
not be enough to persuade wealthier
school districts that don't need the
money one possible solution to the
housing shortage is for the fed to raise
interest rates if mortgages are more
expensive fewer people will want to buy
a house but the lack of housing affects
the rental market as well and simply
making it harder for people to become
homeowners doesn't address the
underlying problem
owning a home is still the primary
method of building wealth for the vast
majority of americans it's something to
pass on to your children and offers the
security and freedom of knowing that
you're not at the mercy of a landlord in
some ways the problem is simple there
aren't enough homes to go around but
fixing it may require a fundamental
power shift in who gets to decide what
gets built and what doesn't
and that's our two cents
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
patron
if you want to know more about the
shortage of skilled trades people check
out this episode of future of work on
the pbs voices channel